joining me today is the author of The
New York Times bestseller rise of the
robots technology and the threat of a
jobless future
Martin Ford welcome to the Rubin report
thanks for having me I'm glad to have
you here sir because dystopian futures
robots Skynet all of it very much in my
wheelhouse and I want you to explain it
all to me are you ready yes definitely
all right let's do it so first off
before we dive directly into robots and
AI and all that just tell me a little
bit about your background what brought
you to writing a book like this okay so
I studied computer engineering in
college and then I worked as an engineer
a design engineer for several years then
I went back and studied business
eventually I ended up starting and
running a small software company up in
Silicon Valley and I ran that for many
years but even in the course of running
that I saw the impact that all this
technology was having on on jobs at my
business and that businesses like it and
that really got me thinking about this
issue and so about 10 years ago in 20
2009 I wrote my first book called the
lights in the tunnel which really argued
that artificial intelligence was going
to be the next big thing in computing
and then it was going to have a dramatic
impact in particular on the job market
and that book did well enough that it
led to an opportunity to write this book
in 2015 which really got you know quite
a bit of attention and since then I've
kind of shifted my career to really be a
futurist focused on what AI and robotics
means for society and for the economy
and especially for the job market so I
think there going to be some huge
challenges there for us right so we're
gonna unpack all of that stuff but when
you were writing about this in 2009
where people say oh now this is just
pure science Vidya I mean I this was an
issue it was very much off the radar
back then it came with a fair amount of
stigma and stigma and the reason is that
this concern or fear that machines might
take a lot of jobs and there might be
unemployment it's it's an old issue it's
come up many times in the past going all
the way back to the Luddites right in
England 200 years ago and so there's
actually this term neo-luddite for a
person that is once again worrying about
this issue and
it was quite stigmatized so in 2009 when
I wrote the book you know I was one of
the the earliest people to get out there
with this but since then things have
definitely changed and I see a lot of
people much more concerned about this
even professional economists and so
forth so there definitely has been a
shift in mentality over this last ten
years when we've seen things like like
the advent of self-driving cars they
look like they're gonna be arriving soon
and so forth what markers were you
seeing back in 2009 or a little bit
before that even that we're sort of
pushing you in this direction but the
most important thing is what you might
call Moore's Law the fact that the power
of computers is accelerating doubling
every two years and it was obvious that
computers were going to get dramatically
more powerful and there had to be an
application for that it has to be
something you can do with that and it
became obvious to me that artificial
intelligence was going to be the thing
and an AI means essentially solving the
same kinds of problems that the human
brain can solve right enemies machines
that in a limited sense are taking on
cognitive capability they're beginning
to think and that means that technology
is going to begin to compete with and
substitute for human being human beings
in a unique way something that we've
never seen before and is that scales
across the whole economy as all kinds of
jobs skilled jobs and unskilled jobs I
think that it becomes pretty clear that
you know it's gonna have dramatic
implications so when people think about
robots I think like there's a there's a
few different ways you can think about
that you can sort of think about AI
which is sort of the same orphis thing
that people sort of don't contextualize
into a physical object then they think
of robots they think of like you know
c-3po and r2d2 and everything else what
if you were just saying robots what what
exactly are you talking right I
especially in this book rise of the
robots I use the very broad meaning for
that basically to mean anything that is
automating something and taking over you
know things that people can do and very
often that's just gonna be software if
you want to be more precise and
technical a robot is when you take
artificial intelligence and you put it
into a physical machine that can
physically manipulate the environment
but what we're talking about is much
broader than that so we're gonna you
know we're already seeing people like
lawyers and doctors being impacted and
it's not physical robots it's something
just software artificial intelligence
and actually you know building physical
robots that have dexterity that can
manipulate the the environment that's
actually one of the hardest aspects of
this and in some ways that where it may
be where progress is gonna be slowest
where in knowledge type work you know
someone that's sitting in front of a
computer doing some routine task
cranking out the same report again and
again that may actually be much easier
to automate then than something physical
so that's interesting so the the idea
part of it is easier to replicate than
the physical part even though you'd
think that just building a robot that
can move the way you want it to move or
something so that seems technically
easier than figuring out how to think
like humans now it seems like that from
our perspective very often the reason is
that to do these knowledge-based jobs
requires a lot of Education and training
right but actually once you implement
the technology it actually can often be
the the reverse the hardest thing to do
is to build a physical robot that has
dexterity that has visual perception
that can can move around the way a
person does think to build as you said
the kind of robot like c-3po from Star
Trek that's totally science fiction we
don't have anything remotely like that
it seems like we're now and again you
see a video on YouTube where they're
getting a little closer you know they've
got it right but you know jumping over
something and ducking under something
exactly you see those robots in
particular from a company called Boston
Dynamics it's doing very impressive
things but those videos are highly
choreographed the robots are controlled
by someone that's outside the picture
this is not a thinking autonomous robot
running around doing stuff by itself
okay so we're not in Terminator land
just yet not not anytime soon at all
that's far in the future but that you
know we shouldn't allow we shouldn't be
distracted from the fact that there are
things happening now they're gonna have
a really dramatic impact but it's not
the science fiction stuff do you see in
the iRobot million and stuff like that
right so how much of the conversation is
about all of this is about what you
referenced a moment ago about just the
speed of technology and that every two
years the power doubles and all that
that were
walking around with iPhones or so you
know we may have supercomputers in our
pocket and the way we can transmit
information across the globe like that
and and just how much of this is just
related to speed more than right that's
you know a very big part of it it is not
just the speed of computers that have
gotten faster and smaller of course and
now they're in our iPhones but it's the
speed of communications bandwidth it's
memory capacity so we've seen this very
broad-based acceleration and technology
and that's a huge part of it the other
things is that that there have been some
breakthroughs in in artificial
intelligence especially in the hottest
area of AI which is called deep learning
or deep neural networks we've seen
dramatic progress there and that's the
thing that's really revolutionising the
field and and the other thing that's
happened is that we are now throughout
our whole economy and society collecting
huge amounts of data right there's all
this data out there that wasn't there
before and this data is basically the
resource that is used to train these
smart algorithms and that's what
artificial intelligence looks like right
now it's primarily machine learning and
this is just gonna be incredibly
disruptive yeah so it's part of the
potential problem here that we're
building things that will be more
powerful than us and we don't really
understand that so it's like we're
putting so much information in our
brains oh maybe our actual physical
brains can't take all this in like we
don't have enough RAM in our physical
brains for all of the information that
we're constantly slamming ourselves to
well it's definitely true to these smart
algorithms I mean they can look at you
know huge amounts of data millions and
millions and millions of data points
right which no human being could do so
we already have algorithms that in a
very narrow sense in terms of doing very
specific things are superhuman right
they can vastly outperform what any
person does and they do things that we
don't really understand it good example
of that would be Wall Street right where
you've got these trading algorithms that
can actually look at machine readable
news I mean companies like Bloomberg
actually make news products that are
designed for machines not for people
these our rhythms can read that news
and then analyze it and then trade on it
within you know tiny fractions of a
second so that would be an example of
where technology is already getting
ahead of what we can understand yeah
what do we do to rein some of it back in
occasionally well I you know there any
lower is it just once we start the
process with anything like this we just
don't know where it you know it's a
difficult question you know they're
gonna be places where we're gonna need
regulation
you can't just rein it in I mean it's
progress it's happening it's happening
in part because of a competitive dynamic
right within capitalism between
companies between Google and Facebook
and Goldman Sachs all competing to build
delay this technology there's also a
competition between United States and
China all of that is going to push it
forward relentlessly and trying to stop
it it's probably kind of a fool's errand
it's probably not possible and and
probably not not really advisable what I
think we have to do are find ways to
adapt to all of this progress and in
some places that may mean certainly
regulation and in other cases it will
mean finding ways to address issues like
unemployment and inequality that will
result from all of this progress yeah so
let's just define some basic terms
because I think we end up throwing out a
lot of big terms here and then people
are confused so just when people are
talking about the algorithm can you just
explain in simple terms what is the
algorithm well and as we're doing this
on YouTube right now we're always
obsessed with the algorithm an algorithm
is just essentially a computer program
it's something that goes step by step
and does something what we've seen
recently though is the emergence of a
new kind of algorithm called machine
learning algorithms and this is what's
really disruptive and the difference
between a machine learning algorithm and
a traditional computer programming
algorithm is did you know historically
some programmer has has sat down and
told the computer to do what to do step
by step with machine learning instead
you've got a smart algorithm that looks
at lots and lots of data and then
figures out for itself what to do so in
essence it's kind of program its program
its itself right yeah so is there a way
to control
then well you is it just actually
uncontrollable because once once it's
learned enough it just doesn't need the
player it's not so much that it's
uncontrollable but that you know we
don't really want to control the whole
point is to to unleash it and let it
learn and do things that doesn't mean
that it's in any sense out of control or
it's a danger to us or anything like
well I would the reason I was asking was
sort of through it through a YouTube
algorithm lens like one of the things
we're finding out is they just want to
keep you clicking all the time right you
know where we put out a long-form show
people are gonna watch a full hour of
our discussion that's not really what
the algorithm wants it wants you from
the way we understand it from some
insiders they want you to constantly be
clicking on videos and basically fall
into this click call to just keep the
machine going more and more and more now
I understand why they want that sort of
attention going in different places and
all that but for what I do I don't love
the algorithm at the moment if that
means right right so that depends on how
they optimize the algorithm but what's
happening there is that you've got
millions and millions of people watching
youtube videos and if they watch an
entire video then that will create a
data point that says you know they were
really interested in this if they if
they start watching you know you know
for a brief time and they click away
then it'll show that they're less
interested and then an algorithm comes
around and looks at millions of those
data points and and can make
recommendations for other videos and and
as you said I think what we've seen is
that the video shown to people become
more extreme right so if you're
interested in something and then you'll
get a more extreme version of that and
that's how to get people to click and a
lot of people have been you know raising
the alarm over that because that is kind
of radicalizing people right so what do
you do about that if you're if you're a
programmer and you're at YouTube and you
don't want people to be radicalized or
just you know even if you just don't
want people to have to just be endlessly
clicking like there's this game to keep
people addicted to all these things and
it's like I understand that we could put
out a zillion clips so I could you know
I could chop everything into two minute
things and we could put them out and it
would probably help us in terms of views
and all of those things but I just don't
want to play that game right technically
I don't think that's a difficult problem
that depends on what the designer wants
to do that but the whole problem is that
the algorithms are designed to make the
most money for Google right that's
what's driving her so it's not I don't
think it's a computer design problem is
it's a capitalism problem a
profitability problem it's the fact that
that Google is a publicly traded
companies and it you know it's investors
want it to make as much money as
possible and that's what drives it to
design algorithms that maximize
profitability so keep your clicker that
that may be the kind of place where
maybe some regulation has to come in and
say you know well you're gonna have to
put some constraint on this if Google
doesn't make the decision to do it so
yes I mean this is where I'm not a
regulation guy but it's like they're
pushing me to my limits I mean this is
what I keep saying about all the tech
companies right now when it comes to
censorship and everything else it's like
they're not giving us much of a choice
here right I mean it's a challenging
problem for sure - to figure out you
know for AI to figure out what's in a
video and in terms of is there something
there that should be censored or not
that's the decision they're making and
that's that's quite different from from
just optimizing getting people to watch
you videos because in order to do that
you know you don't care what's in the
video that's the whole problem right
right it's just tracking statistics but
if you actually want to analyze what's
in a video is there something there it
is dangerous are you inciting people to
violence or something like that for
artificial intelligence to figure that
out is still much much harder now that
that's why we're running into this
problematic how is deep learning
different than artificial intelligence
that's that's just the next level of
artificial deep learning is a kind of of
artificial intelligence is right now the
hottest area of AI and deep learning or
deep neural networks basically means a
system that is loosely designed on the
way a brain would work it has artificial
neurons that are roughly similar to to
the neurons in your brain and that's the
way it works and this is an idea that's
been around you know for since the 1950s
at least but just within the last six
years or so we've seen just an explosion
in this technology and we've now got
systems that can translate languages
from Chinese to English that can
and do better than people at recognising
visual images we've got with radiology
systems that can look at medical images
and find cancer there and in some cases
can do that better than human doctors so
this is absolutely absolutely the
hottest area of AI it's also what's
enabling self-driving cars for example
so is this the great catch-22 of all of
robotics is that it's doing these
incredible things and then as you talked
about in the book it's gonna put a lot
of people out of work as well I think
that's one of the the real problems with
it I mean and you know we're ultimately
going to have to make a choice as to
whether we want to allow that progress
to continue and get the enormous
benefits of that progress but if that's
gonna come at a cost of making some set
of our population unemployable or or
maybe de-skilling jobs to the point
where people just don't have adequate
income even if they don't even if they
do have a job hmm then we've got to find
a way to adapt to that right and that's
why for example I've talked a lot about
a universal basic income is your own
possible approach to that but I'm very
much against the idea that we should
stop progress because this is where we
are you know this is what the rest is
gonna look like in the future we don't
want to stop it because progress is the
thing that has made us better off over
is there any evidence that ever in
history you could stop progress actually
even if we wanted to stop it right let's
say you laid out the greatest case why
this thing is gonna run out of control
it's gonna put half of us out of
business
you know the income inequality is gonna
go crazy poverty etc etc is there any
case where technology existed that we
somehow put the put the brakes on it I'd
be quite skeptical that we'd be able to
do that again in part because of
competition not just between companies
but between countries maybe we would do
it but then China didn't put the brakes
on and they would pretty soon be vastly
ahead of us right so that would be a
problem is that the catch-22 then for
regulation because it's like we may try
to regulate some of it but if China is
not regulating it or if they're exactly
that one of you know that's one of the
biggest problems is that you would you
would put your country at a disadvantage
unless you could do it on a global basis
and of course doing anything on a global
basis is incredibly hard as you see with
climate change for example
so again my perspective is that rather
than trying to slow it down what we
should do is find a way to adapt to it
let just let it run but understand what
the implications are gonna be and figure
out a way to adapt to that
yeah and that's where the idea of a
basic income comes in so I want to talk
a little bit more about ubi but before
we do that can you talk a little bit
just about how this has affected certain
industries and how some industries
haven't quite been affected yet right so
in general the point that would make is
it is gonna affect everything I mean
artificial intelligence is gonna be like
a utility it's gonna be like electricity
right and no one says what industries
are most impacted by electricity I mean
you know everything relies on
electricity right and the same will be
true of artificial intelligence and
machine learning so in the long run is
everywhere in the near term clearly you
know manufacturing has already been
impacted by automation generally we've
seen a dramatic decrease in advanced
countries and the number of people
employed in manufacturing that's going
to continue the robots and the
automation used in factories is gonna
get a lot more effective more dexterous
they'll be able to do the jobs that
right now only people can do but it's
gonna scale to many many other areas in
finance it's gonna have a dramatic
impact a lot of white-collar jobs there
where people are sitting in front of a
computer cracking out reports or
something right
recently I saw something that a CEO of
Deutsche Bank one of the big banks said
he thought he could get rid of half of
his employees in a relatively near
future using using this technology
healthcare is an is an area where it's
gonna be slower because it's really hard
you've got doctors and nurses that need
to engage with patients on a one-on-one
basis right and provide a lot of
individual human-like service and it's
been and that's one of the reasons that
healthcare costs are so high in the
United States right now because we have
not seen the kind of productivity
increases there that we've seen in
saying manufacturing right so what what
could we do to see that well we're
beginning to see evidence of that as I
mentioned you've got systems now that
can read medical images so you're going
to begin to see the introduction of
artificial intelligence in medicine
think that it will for the most part
least in the near term it's not going to
completely replace doctors but it will
become kind of a second opinion
it will run alongside a doctor you know
always be there we'll make every doctor
be able to perform at the level of the
best doctor right because because
there'll be this incredible intelligence
there so that will be of enormous
benefit there and then eventually if you
just extrapolate that down the road it
could replace the doctor to write a
short surgery like in the movie alien
and a million other things exactly amano
i would say in general doctors are
relatively safe because they are highly
regulated right there are all kinds of
rules about medicine and and you need to
have a doctor or a pharmacist there and
those go so those rules are relatively
protect protected where if you're a
white-collar job in some corporations
sitting in a cubicle somewhere you don't
have any protections at all so for that
reason I would worry a bit less about
doctors disappearing in an inner term
but you know in health care there
definitely are gonna be lots of
applications you already see robots in
hospitals delivering things you see
robots beginning to be used in elder
care looking after older people which is
certainly one of the biggest
opportunities because we have this aging
population Pharmacy robots who are huge
things they're already robots that do
you know thousands and thousands of
prescriptions in hospitals and so forth
very efficiently so this is coming it
will take a little bit longer in
healthcare than in some other areas but
eventually it's going to be everywhere
in retail you know they're there
Walmart is beginning to introduce robots
and of course retailing general is
migrating more and more toward Amazon
yeah which in theory means that jobs you
know MIT they might move from a retail
store to an Amazon warehouse but once
the jobs go to that Amazon warehouse now
they're in a very controlled environment
mm-hmm and there are already lots of
robots there and those robots are gonna
get dramatically better in the next five
or ten years so in effect you could have
a giant Amazon warehouse that we've all
driven by one of these these huge
monstrosity x' and it could basically be
run by all robots and your
a lot fewer people I mean right now
inside those room inside those
warehouses you have huge numbers of
robots and the robots will do something
like bring a whole shelf of inventory to
a worker but then the workers got to
reach in there and grab the item off the
shelf mm-hmm and put it in a box because
the robot right now can't do that it
doesn't have the visual perception and
the dexterity to do that yeah but that
will change over the next five to ten
years and so those environments are
going to become a lot less
labor-intensive that's not to say
they'll be fully automated but they're
gonna be fewer jobs there and that's
something to worry about because this is
one of the brightest areas right now for
job creation right so we're gonna so
we're gonna watch a certain sector or
many sectors of jobs just disappear
altogether and yet at the same time I
guess the counter-argument or the people
that would say we shouldn't be so
alarmed about this would say well all
the cost of everything will go down
because the robots will be able to do
things that are much more efficient
cheaper level right so people won't need
as much disposable income that sort of
thing that's right I mean that that's
absolutely true there I I'm very
skeptical that that kind of solves the
problem no me you can think about it if
you don't have a job at all then your
income is zero it doesn't matter doesn't
matter how the other thing is that the
really big ticket items the things that
really are putting people under water
are housing education health care and
these are exactly the areas where
technology is at least in the short and
medium term gonna have the least impact
right I mean housing in particular
someday we might have big 3d printers
that make it really cheap to produce
housing but but there's still a problem
with land right and if you're in Los
Angeles or up in San Francisco then
there's no land right it's already you
know you know it's already very scarce
and that's what drives property values
so high so you can't solve that problem
necessarily just with technology yeah so
as incomes fall you know many people are
not gonna have the income to really
cover it the basics and that that's
gonna be a big problem okay so that's
the right transition then to universal
basic income so my my default position
on ubi and I've heard arguments on both
sides and I think I told you I've Andrew
yang coming in soon and we'll discuss it
further
my default position is that
if you give people just enough to
survive that you're sort of stealing
just like the most basic human right of
just like go get something for yourself
and that it's gonna create this class of
people sort of not by their own fault
that we'll just have the bare minimum to
get by and then they'll be able to stay
at home and play video games and watch
porn and basically do nothing all day
long and will and that's actually taking
for something from them rather than
giving something to them that's sort of
my sort of like high-level philosophic
position on it right the argument I
would make is that once a society who
reaches a certain level of prosperity as
we have if you want to continue to have
capitalism and a market it's very
important to have the kind of incentive
that you're alluding to there yeah but I
would argue that maybe the incentive
doesn't have to be so daunting that if
you don't work you're living on the
street or eating out of garbage cans
right that maybe it's enough to say that
you can basically survive if you're not
motivated but you're not gonna have a
terrific life you're not gonna have a
great life and I think that that a
number of studies have been done with
basic income that showed that when you
give people this money they don't in
fact just drop out and stay home and do
nothing they are actually motivated to
do something more they invest in their
family and education they work if they
can they maybe start a small business so
actually if you give people that basic
safety net you can create an environment
where people are actually more willing
to take risks so for example they might
start a new business
they might be willing to leave a safe
job where they're not learning anything
they're not growing and work for a
start-up company do something more risky
right but is the inherent problem that
then if they start getting some success
then they lose the ubi and no no that's
that's yeah the whole solution yeah
to a basic income and that's what makes
it different from other forms of safety
is that it is unconditional in the sense
that everyone gets it now what that
means is that if I get my basic income
and I choose to just play video games
then I'll have that basic income but if
someone else is more ambitious they get
their basic income and they go and work
even if it's only part-time they
to small business then they they get the
basic income and they also get that
additional income we don't tax it away
at least not at the lower level so the
key point is that the person that is
productive that is willing to do
something to work will always be better
off than the person that does nothing
right and that's really key to it
because the problem with our existing
social safety net is exactly what you
said that if you do something find a job
then you lose those benefits yeah and so
that the cliff has to be really hiding
to be willing to leave right and that's
exactly what's called a poverty trap
right you get into a situation where you
look at the options around you and and
anything you do doesn't make you better
offer you know and she works often so
you're stuck there you can't move the
worst possible example of that in United
States is the Social Security disability
program right which is intended for
people to injured on the job and then it
can't work but actually a lot of people
now are gaming it probably because
they're desperate they need an income
and so they'll go and tell their doctor
they've got pain in their back or
something and they'll get through the
loops and they'll get on to this program
which gives you an income once you get
there you can't even be seen to be able
bodied people are worried even to go and
work in their garden or something
because someone will see them and then
they'll lose their benefits right so
that's a really terrible example of this
kind of income where a basic income we
give it to everyone and it's
unconditional and then we encourage
people to do more right and that that
that's really important that's one of
the strongest arguments for a basic
income scheme yeah so let's get into
some of the nuts and bolts of it first
off do you view it as something that
would have to be done federally because
obviously if you live in Los Angeles or
San Francisco your cost of living is way
higher than say if you live in Missouri
right so is this a is this a federal
program are we throwing this to the
state's imagine it needs to be done on a
national level and the reason is what
you can think of it's kind of like the
kind of adverse selection problem you
get in in insurance right if Los Angeles
has a basic income then people all over
the country are going to move to Los
Angeles to get that right and they're
gonna show up here and and overwhelm the
system so it needs to be national rather
then local right but what do you do
about the disparity and cost of living
in all these ways well you know one
issue there is that a basic income is
mobile right so maybe you don't have to
live in Los Angeles or San Francisco you
can take your basic income and you can
move to Detroit right and there you
might have a pretty decent life you can
have housing they're much cheaper right
so the difference between a basic income
and a job is that you can take it
everywhere so people would kind of
readjust and they might some people
might choose to leave leave high-cost
areas and and live in cheaper places and
so forth so how do you fund all this
that always is the big one are you
scrapping all the social programs that
exist right now or you're taxing
billionaires out the wazoo some
combination there you know do you think
definitely you need to raise more
revenue I think inevitably one of the
things that that we are seeing with the
economy largely as the result of
technology is that more and more income
is going to capital unless it's going to
labour so businesses and investors and
people like that are getting more income
and average working people are getting
less so what that means for the future I
think it's inevitable that we're gonna
have to tax capital more and labor less
and that may you know involve higher
business taxes or taxes on the
wealthiest people that have accessed a
lot lots of capital mean that that's as
a libertarian you might find that
objectionable but I think it's
inevitable you ultimately if you're
gonna have a taxation scheme you have to
tax the people to have the money right
you can't you can't get blood from a
rock as they say right right so well how
do you decide what the level is now I
get you could live in LA and the cost of
living is high and then maybe you'd say
alright well I can't I can't make it
here in a way I want to so I want to go
somewhere achieve but how do you figure
out well what is it that is the basic
stuff and the record well you know it's
ubi so what is the basic stuff that
people are supposed to have well I mean
the in terms of the level of the income
most people are talking about around a
thousand dollars a month Finland had an
experiment where it was like 600 euros
or something so these are pretty low
amounts I mean you know try you imagine
living on a thousand dollars a month
right
I used to do it yeah it's not so easy so
I think one advantage of these programs
is the they're gonna start at a low
level and we can imagine as technology
advances and and society becomes more
prosperous that that could be raised
over time but initially it's gonna be a
very low level so I don't think we have
to worry too much about destroying the
incentive for people to work and so
forth they give people a very very
minimal cushion but they're still gonna
have that incentive to work right it's
so interesting because it just does set
all my libertarian bells off that well
the second you give it to somebody so we
give a thousand bucks to everybody well
immediately you're gonna have
politicians saying this isn't enough and
it's then we have to make it more and we
have to make it more in that then that
becomes the cycle where we're always
shifting money around and it's just
because no one's ever gonna no matter
what basic level we get most people - no
one's ever gonna be like alright well
okay that's a real concern I would say
though that you know a basic income or
there are other flavors of the
guaranteed minimum income and negative
income tax these are ideas that in the
past have been embraced by libertarians
Friedrich Hayek was a big proponent of a
guaranteed minimum income Milton
Friedman was for a negative income tax
and the idea is that you're creating
really a market-based safety net right
rather than having government house
people feed people control industries or
try to take over businesses and run them
in a way that artificially creates jobs
and so forth rather than doing that just
give people some money let them go out
and participate in the market so it
actually is a market oriented
libertarian approach to having some kind
of safety net but I think your the idea
of it being politicized that's a real
concern one one thing I actually have
suggested and some of my writing is that
we might set up a separate institution
to kind of manage that maybe something
like the Federal Reserve mm-hmm it would
be independent and not part of the
political process and might manage the
level of of a basic income because you
could actually use it also to to respond
to recessions for example if there's an
economic down
maybe pay people a bit more mm-hmm and
then that would help you get out of the
recession right it would be kind of a
Keynesian response to it so I think
there are a lot of possibilities Debra
you're right we don't we don't want
every politician running on the platform
of I will increase your basic income
right that wouldn't be good right yeah
and that just strikes me as sort of real
politic related to all of this it's just
the way people are once you give them
something they want more I don't blame
people for that it's just sort of exact
the way people are it's the way politics
work so that's something that we need to
think about from the beginning as I said
you know maybe you put it in the hands
of a separate institution what other
thing I proposed is that maybe we can
build incentives into a basic income if
people stay in school paid them a bit
more than people that just play video
games where people go and work in the
community you know help other people pay
pay them a bit more so that I think it's
really important to have sort of a
ladder for people then they feel they
can somehow do better because that I
mean the issue you raised everywhere a
raised before that we could create this
class of people that just you know do
nothing is is something to be concerned
about but there are ideas that we can I
think employ to really address that
[Music]